en vez de tener un diálogo de verdad
buscando un acuerdo lo que tenemos es
intoxicación
informativa y provocaciones
las mentiras de occidente
chocaban la confianza en las
instituciones internacionales y en el
derecho internacional como garantía de
justicia y de protección de los débiles
estas tendencias negativas que vemos
también en la ONU
después de acabar con el nazismo y el
militarismo japonés se crearon se creó
la ONU para evitar el conflicto entre
los miembros
pero lo cierto es que el futuro del
orden mundial se decide hoy y es claro
para cualquier observador objetivo
sí estamos buscando el beneficio
hegemónico o más bien la democracia y la
justicia sin chantajes
y sin
meter el miedo a través del neonacismo y
el
neocolonialismo junto con otros países
pedimos a todos que opten
por la vía de las soluciones se acaba el
modelo unipolar del mundo que servía los
intereses de unos pocos
su consumo excesivo viene de los
recursos de Asia de África y
de otras de otros continentes los
pueblos ahora quieren defender sus
intereses con una nueva arquitectura
multipolar Pero estos procesos
Washington
los ve como digo Washington y sus
súbditos como una amenaza a Estados
Unidos y sus aliados Quieren poner fin a
la marcha de la historia
declararon que habían ganado la guerra
fría y se erigieron en los enviados de
Dios
sobre la Tierra
como si no tuviera obligaciones solo el
derecho sagrado actual con total
impunidad
contra cualquier estado
siempre que
se le atrevan a desafiar a estos países
recordamos la guerra de agresión en
yugoslavia en Irak en Libia que han
causado cientos de miles de muertos
se veían afectados los
intereses de estos países Allí
se ha prohibido su cultura en los medios
de comunicación su idioma se declaró que
los anglosajones eran inhumanos
porque intervinieron en estas aventuras
por ejemplo en Oriente medio ha mejorado
la situación de Derechos Humanos es
mejor el estado de derecho la situación
socioeconómica se ha estabilizado vive
la gente mejor díganme ustedes un país
en los que ha intervenido Estados Unidos
en los que haya mejorado la vida
el intentar establecer el modelo
unilateral
bajo la excusa del orden normativo
Estados Unidos Busca la confrontación
entre los bloques están ustedes con
nosotros o en contra de nosotros no
buscan el término medio
quieren extender la otan hacia el este
hacia las fronteras de Rusia
Estados Unidos ahora quiere subyugar
también hacia en la Cumbre de junio de
la otan en Madrid
esta
Alianza supuestamente defensiva hablaba
de la seguridad
en lo atlántica y del Pacífico
en esta estrategia se han creado
formatos que socaban por ejemplo los
resultados de trabajo de hace años su
arquitectura abierta regional están
jugando con fuego también en Taiwán
están prometiendo apoyo a Taiwán está
claro que la doctrina Monroe vuelve a
ser global Washington intenta
convertir a todo el mundo en su propio
patio trasero
y para ello requieren a sanciones
unilaterales ilícitas desde hace años en
violación de la carta como herramienta
de chantaje político su cinismo es
patente porque esta restricciones
afectan a los civiles les impiden el
acceso a los bienes básicos medicamentos
vacunas alimentos un ejemplo clarísimo
lo tenemos en el bloqueo de Cuba desde
hace más de 60 años la asamblea desde
hace muchísimo tiempo ha pedido
que se levante inmediatamente este
embargo el secretario general
que tiene que aplicar las decisiones de
la asamblea tiene que prestar atención a
esta cuestión el secretario general
tiene un papel clave en la movilización
[Música]
contra la crisis energética y
alimentaria
por la emisión incontrolada de dinero de
Estados Unidos y de la Unión Europea
durante la pandemia esta
irresponsabilidad
también se aplica al mercado de
hidrocarburos en la Unión Europea
Washington y Bruselas han empeorado la
situación al lanzar una guerra económica
contra Rusia por ello ha aumentado el
precio de los alimentos del petróleo de
los fertilizantes damos las gracias al
secretario general
por su apoyo al acuerdo de Estambul el
24 de junio Pero tiene que aplicarse
hasta ahora los barcos con grano
ucraniano No van a los países más pobres
como hemos podido constatar Por otra
parte los impedimentos de Estados Unidos
y de la Unión Europea a nivel financiero
lagístico contra nuestras exportaciones
de grano y fertilizantes no se han
levantado desde hace semanas llevamos
diciendo que tenemos 300.000 toneladas
de fertilizantes en los puertos europeos
hemos propuesto que sean bien
gratuitamente a los países que lo
necesitan en África pero la Unión
Europea no quiere la rusofobia de
occidente no tiene precedentes es
grotesca
declaran sus intenciones de
militar militarmente a nuestro país de
destruir la de fragmentar la lo que
quieren hacer es quitar a Rusia del mapa
una entidad geopolítica que es demasiado
independiente para ellos
que he hecho
década Rusia en las últimas décadas que
violaciones ha cometido
impedimos Los acuerdos de Dayton
hemos desarrollado la reunificación de
Alemania sin
precondiciones dijimos que retiraríamos
a nuestros militares de
Europa de latinoamérica reconocimos la
independencia de la repúblicas
soviéticas creímos en las promesas de
los líderes occidentales de no ampliar
la otra en Europa del este
quemamos un acuerdo con ellos les
dijimos que era inaceptable el aceptar
esta estructura militar ofensiva a
nuestras fronteras la arrogancia de los
europeos y de los americanos son muy
destructivas tras el final de la Guerra
Fría ya en el año 91
en el pentágono
en sus conversaciones
con los comandantes de la otan ropa con
Wesley claro concretamente decía que
tras el fin de la guerra fría y cito
podemos utilizar a nuestros militares
sin miedo a la represalias tenemos 5-10
años
para limpiar el
régimen
de Rusia de Irak de Siria hasta que haya
otros superpotencia que pueda cuestionar
Estas actividades estoy convencido de
que
en las memorias de alguien encontraremos
la historia de cómo se desarrolló la
estrategia americana en Ucrania pero los
planes se resultan evidentes en este
caso los de Washington
la solicitud de Estados Unidos y de la
Unión Europea
apoyamos en el acuerdo con el presidente
yanukovic de Ucrania con las fuerzas de
la oposición para resolver la crisis en
febrero del 2014 acuerdos garantizados
por Alemania Polonia y Francia pero la
mañana siguiente los ignoraron los
líderes del golpe de estado de
sangriento que humilló a occidente
occidente se encogió de hombros y
empezaron a bombear
este de Ucrania donde no se aceptó el
resultado del golpe de estado
se hizo
Héroes a los Cómplices de los nazis
tenemos que
aceptar que quien prohíba la educación y
el idioma y la cultura rusa
su obsesión con expulsar a los rusos de
crimea su guerra contra dombas sus
propios ciudadanos
hemos violado nosotros los intereses de
occidente Quizás por nuestro papel en
la oposición a los neonazis de kiev en
el este de Ucrania
chef con la con el apoyo de Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea ha ignorado
las disposiciones del Consejo desde hace
años hemos hecho propuestas de seguridad
en Europa sobre la
premisa de los documentos de la osc
según el los cuales Nadie debe reforzar
su seguridad a expensas de los otros
se hizo la propuesta de que estos
acuerdos fueran vinculantes lo dijimos
en 2021 pero la redacción de occidente
fue Simplemente un rechazo arrogante
como siempre la incapacidad de occidente
para negociar y la guerra de kiev contra
su propio pueblo no nos dejó otra opción
que reconocer la independencia de estas
regiones y empezar una operación
especial para proteger a estas regiones
y evitar la amenaza contra nuestra
seguridad creada por la otan en Ucrania
en nuestras fronteras la operación
cumple Pues los acuerdos de asistencia
mutua entre nosotros y esta repúblicas y
en virtud del artículo 51 de la carta
estoy convencido de que cualquier estado
soberano haría lo mismo en nuestro lugar
Si comprende su responsabilidad es para
con su propio pueblo
el occidente ahora
le ha dado un patatús
por el referéndum
que se celebra en estas regiones de
Ucrania Pero los que viven allí
simplemente están reaccionando
a lo que ha hecho el señor Celeste en
agosto del 2021 en su momento dijo los
que se sientan rusos En beneficio de sus
hijos y de sus nietos salgan del país y
vayanse a Rusia y eso es lo que han
hecho los habitantes de esta regiones y
se han llevado su tierra con ellos la
tierra de sus ancestros desde hace
siglos cualquier observador Imparcial
puede ver claramente que los
anglosajones que han subido a Europa
para ello los ucranianos Es simplemente
Carne de cañón la otan ha declarado que
nuestro país es una amenaza inmediata
occidente bajo el liderazgo de
Washington amenaza también a otros
países diciendo que los que desobedezcan
serán los siguientes una de las
consecuencias de la Cruzada de Occidente
es la reducción del multilateralismo
que se han convertido estas
instituciones en herramientas que
utiliza occidente para su propio interés
en la ONU el consejo de Derechos Humanos
UNESCO y otros foros multilaterales
la organización para la provisión de
armas químicas ha sido privatizada
claramente se hace lo posible
se hace lo mismo también en la
convención sobre
toxinas y programas biológicos que
afectaría a las existencias que tiene
Estados Unidos en todo el mundo
programas que son muy dañinos es algo
irrefutable
lo hemos visto en Ucrania
se quiere privatizar la secretaría de
Naciones Unidas también con una
narrativa neoliberal que ignora la
cultura y la civilización
de otras regiones del mundo pedimos
que se siga la carta
y que se dé una representación
geográfica equitativa para que no haya
un país que domine la secretaría
Washington ha creado también una
situación imposible en relación a sus
obligaciones como país anfitrión en
virtud del acuerdo de sede para
garantizar las condiciones de
participación de todos los miembros en
el trabajo de la ONU
el secretario general también tiene
estas obligaciones su inestabilidad su
inactividad es inaceptable otros países
quieren también socavar las
prerrogativas del Consejo de Seguridad
Lo cierto es que la ONU tiene que estar
en línea con la realidad contemporánea
queremos un consejo
más
democrático
ampliando la representación de África y
latinoamérica y Asia India y Brasil son
actores internacionales claves y buenos
candidatos a miembros permanentes
al mismo tiempo
Es necesario dar mucha más
visibilidad a África en el consejo de
seguridad
todos tenemos que reafirmar nuestro
compromiso con la carta para establecer
nuestra responsabilidad colectiva con el
destino de la humanidad por eso en julio
del 2021 un grupo de amigos en apoyo de
la carta se creó oficialmente Nosotros
somos como patrocinadores
y el grupo Integra ahora a 20 países
Nuestro objetivo es velar porque se
cumpla plenamente las normas de derecho
internacional en contra del
unilateralismo pedimos a todos que se
sumen a esta iniciativa
esta organización tiene mucho potencial
así como el movimiento no alineado y
otros los colegas occidentales son muy
agresivos a la hora de imponer su visión
de la democracia
para organizarle la vida a todos los
países
ellos desde luego nos siguen las normas
democráticas en los asuntos
internacionales como vemos en Ucrania de
nuevo parece
que Rusia justificado su postura
y occidente no está de acuerdo
Qué opinan otros miembros de la
comunidad internacional tienen que poder
decidir con libertad estar con unos con
otros o ser neutrales eso es lo que
ocurre en la democracia cuando hay
diferencias políticas estos defienden
sus puntos de vistas
pero Estados Unidos y sus aliados no
dejan elegir amenazan le retuercen el
brazo a todo el mundo a todo aquel que
quiera pensar de manera
independientemente y exigen con amenazas
que los países se sumen a las sanciones
antirrosas esto no les Funciona muy bien
pero resulta patente que estos actos de
Estados Unidos y de sus satélites no son
democráticos es una dictadura clarísima
vemos Que Washington y la Europa
subyugada por los americanos
en la desaparición de su hegemonía y
para ello utilizan
medios ilícitos sanciones ilegales
contra sus competidores económicos en el
ámbito de la información la cultura
que ocurre por ejemplo con los visados
para los delegados en reuniones en
Ginebra París Nueva York ahí claramente
se quiere evitar la competencia para que
no haya puntos de vista alternativos en
los debates multilaterales estoy
convencido de que tenemos que proteger a
la ONU y evitar la confrontación
y devolver la reputación a la ONU como
plata forma de búsqueda de soluciones
para todos los estados miembros Esta es
nuestra perspectiva en nuestras
iniciativas es fundamental
prohibir
el uso de armas en el espacio por ello
Rusia y China quieren redactar un
tratado a examinar en la conferencia de
desarme es importante también proteger
el ciber espacio
y el trabajo que realiza el grupo de la
asamblea general al respecto
para proteger la seguridad internacional
utilizando el comité
correspondiente
que se ocupa de la lucha contra el oso
criminal de las teices con fines
terroristas seguimos apoyando la lucha
antiterrorista y a las entidades
antiterroristas de la ONU y seguidiendo
Seguiremos Perdón desarrollando nuestra
relación con la ONU la organización de
seguridad
la comunidad de Estados independientes
para dar más
visibilidad a la colaboración con
eurasia queremos también superar los
conflictos regionales y pensamos que la
prioridad aquí es superar el
estancamiento en la creación de un
estado palestino
y
recuperar o reconstruir línea destruida
por la agresión de la otan y tener un
proceso de Reconciliación nacional en
yemen superar la presencia de la otan en
Afganistán estamos trabajando para
restablecer también el plan nuclear con
Irán
para resolver Igualmente también el
problema de la Península de Corea la
compleja situación de África requiere
rechazar la tentación de
los juegos de suma cero
hemos de apoyar las iniciativas de La
Unión africana nos preocupa la situación
en Cosmo y kosovo y Bosnia herzegovina
que está llevando a la destrucción del
orden jurídico internacional tal como
establecen las resoluciones
correspondientes y el acuerdo de daito
en tiempos como estos Es lógico Buscar
la cabalidad de nuestros predecesores en
palabras del ex secretario general de
hamas Hold que recordaba los horrores de
la Guerra Mundial dijo y citó la ONU no
fue creada para llevar a la humanidad al
paraíso sino para salvar a la humanidad
del infierno son palabras de lo más
apropiadas nos piden que entendamos
nuestra responsabilidad responsabilidad
responsabilidad individual y colectiva
de crear un desarrollo Pacífico y
armonioso para las generaciones futuras
y todo el mundo de mostrar voluntad
política estamos dispuestos a realizar
esta labor honesta y estamos convencidos
de que se puede garantizar la
estabilidad del orden mundial Si
volvemos únicamente a los orígenes de la
di de Naciones Unidas a partir del
principio básico de la Democracia
respecto a las igualdad soberanía de los
estados gracias